one of the most exciting things I'm
looking forward to in the next five or
ten years is the development of cheap
affordable education which can be
delivered by broadband by internet by
mobile phones by many different
techniques to the masses of the world
particularly in the emerging economies
countries like India in China which need
affordable education very very badly and
yet the cost of that education today and
the way it's delivered is completely
output it's not in sync with technology
it's not in sync with where the world
goes most important it's not in sync
with the way people would want to get
educated so can we deliver education can
we do skills development at $50.00 of
course can we deliver then of courses
and $100 of course can we deliver
graduate programs at $500 of course that
development is happening a lot of people
are working on it they were working on
both content and delivery and cost and
if we can get it down to that affordable
level I think it would be one of the
most exciting developments the world
could ever have because it will
transform the way the poor of the world
think and it will make them become a lot
more inclusive with the rest of the
world card